nuevamente Ucrania acaparó la atención
de este foro económico mundial el
presidente ucraniano bolodimir selenski
se dirigió a los más de 2.700 asistentes
Aquí en al Foro en davos y para pedirle
a occidente más ayuda militar que llegue
más rápido antes de que Rusia decida
recrudecer aún más su ofensiva sobre
este país también pidió un minuto de
silencio por las víctimas de la guerra
concretamente de su ministro del
interior y su comitiva quienes
fallecieron en un accidente de
helicóptero y aunque dijo que las causas
del accidente están por conocerse o por
investigarse mejor si es una
consecuencia directa de la guerra hoy Se
cerraron filas en torno a la petición
entonces de que llegue más ayuda militar
a Ucrania el presidente de Polonia lo
solicitó el canciller Alemán Olaf shows
quien estuvo acá dando un muy esperado
discurso dijo que lo único que debe
garantizarse es que no haya una guerra
entre Rusia y la otan al suministrar los
tanques lío parte 2 de fabricación
alemana que es lo que han venido
pidiendo Los Socios occidentales
precisamente el jefe de la
otanberg también hizo un llamado para
que la ayuda llegue más rápido pues dice
que si Rusia se rinde en el en el frente
de batalla puede llegar a una solución
negociada de la guerra